what's up kids happy holiday happy
hanukkah happy
christmas merry christmas you know the
gig
hopefully uh it's gonna be a good
holiday we're gonna wrap this year up
and thank god 2020 is ending uh bring in
the new year with your boys here west
palm beach december 31st through january
2nd
then san marcos texas january 29th
through the 30th
uh right outside austin san marcos texas
we coming
but next week thursday friday saturday
we in florida west palm beach get your
sorry get some kratom down my throat
we're at west palm beach
uh thursday friday saturday get your
tickets florida get your tan asses there
tfatk.com for tickets thick boy
thinkboy.com
you can get your brand new thick smiley
gear hoodies
tees hats sweats we got it all
uh think boys short sleeve hoodies thick
boy tie dye thick boy hats
we got it all think boy nation
thickboy.com
this episode is brought to you by the
one the only gift the gift that keeps on
giving we talking about health man
talking about the best supplements the
best workout gear on it.com
fighter 10 off the entire goddamn
website
whatever you need man total gut health
super important uh new
mood we got alpha brain we got krill oil
joint oil
protein powders we got workout gear
kettle bells
uh battle ropes everything streaming
fitness there's no reason you have to go
to the gym do it from your living room
get your thick ass
on the ground streaming from your phone
on at 6
streaming fitness uh again kettlebells
steel club maces sandbags battle ropes
everything you need
to get your thick ass fat ass in shape
on it.com slash fighter 10
this paper straw too oh yes those are
kind of weird because i'd rather kill a
few turtles man
than just got a paper straw a couple of
them
or what people just throwing straws in
the ocean and [ __ ] apparently that's
what they showed a picture of like a
turtle in the ocean with a straw out of
his nose like do you all really need
plastic straws yeah
if you stupid enough to eat a straw
that's on you baby
just swim around it that's on you big
turtle they're not eating straws
yeah they are they are oh yeah they'll
eat anything yeah
they'll eat anything man it's malik's
birthday you're 42 years old
whose birthday is it
you 44 birthdays yeah you're going wrong
you look great at 44. i'm older how old
are you though i'm 29. i keep telling
you still doing it man i know right
still doing doing this
you're 33 30 you're young too yeah my
birthday's a month away
i know your birthday's all right a month
away
23rd january 23rd yeah shout out to the
january 23rd
uh what sign are you a queer doesn't
matter right i can't believe you asked
when i
answered what the [ __ ] i literally
answered
like i'm [ __ ] looking to what an
aquarius i'm actually an aquarius um
pretty strong mind yeah
that's what [ __ ] do all the time
right right you were interested
i know my actually my my win signed is
um pisces yeah i'm pretty easy going and
i'd love to be around the ocean i'm
compatible with aries
i get i get along well with tauruses are
you a taurus
that's all these [ __ ] dumbasses
thoughts bro so funny
i mean people believe in it what's up
with don what sign are you malik
scorpio i'm a capricorn capricorn i know
yeah it's capricorn
i thought december i thought like
november december that sagittarius oh so
he's
yeah december something through january
like
20th or 19th is capricorns and what's
why do i know that don't ask me my mom's
super into this stuff oh she is
super into it it's it's like when i was
younger i'd like
you know i'd be dating a girl my mom
like what sign is she like i don't i
don't know let's read one right
what's your sign uh pisces read let's
read today's pisces and see if that's
accurate
do you ever feel that way yeah uh the i
mean some of it
some of it yeah somebody you look at
you're like damn i wonder how they did
it i can tell you a sign my ex was a
pisces
oh yeah i could tell you that she liked
to be around water pretty easy going
yeah big hands big dick what wait what
wait what i'm sorry you say pisces yes i
pissed oh that's no that's not that was
you
wait what are you you describe the tours
this how rappers when they about to
premiere this track and they get oh
you're are you nervous about your diss
track i'm not nervous now
it's your birthday guest we're like yeah
yeah let's do we're letting you hear
this
stuff on the i'm firing the kids yeah
yeah i feel good about it
you feel good about it i've been great
i'm feeling cake yeah feeling great can
you give him the origin story
before we premiere tell him how it
started how it started sure
so you were dating a girl yeah big sean
[ __ ] your girl don't say it like that
now man hey if you want me to do it
i'm gonna do it
so you're dating this little philly bird
and she slended
she slid into big sean's dna oh they did
she was that she was just take down your
video
no a restaurant she was that he was she
was a host at the restaurant and he uh
oh even better she was a host at the
restaurant and he spit he put game on
her
well i was picking her up oh [ __ ] no
and before she got in your car she gave
him her digits yeah
and then wait and then what restaurant
was it can we say that
um tell me and then we'll bleep it out
yeah okay
so so what we'll edit out the name of
the restaurant but fans will figure out
so big sean went to go reach for that
[ __ ]
fortune cookie and was like what's up
girl what's up girl well here's the
thing
she was very unprofessional because uh
he slid her a tip
and uh his number oh and
yeah why are you okay okay so wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait all right yeah
keep going
i'm about to pick her up and she he know
he see me
i was like bro it's my girl you know i
say that but i don't think that happens
i gave him a look i gave him that look
like hold on i bet i bet he saw you
i
so i bet he he was getting picked up in
like his he had a base
he had a bands right probably a s-class
and looked at you it was like a black
and black
so so how long after that did she come
over and get that big dick
so later on like during that week she
said she was going out with the girls
and i figured i was like i bet she said
she'll be home around like one
something like that right so it gets one
i call her a caller
it's going straight to voicemail she
butt down me back
oh and what'd you hear i heard i heard
him do you want to have another drink
and uh it's like it was intimate and i
heard like and then did you hear the
background i don't know
wait that's a big sean line in one of
his songs what
uh he the line was something along the
lines of like
him but dialing his girl and she hears
girls screaming the whole night
like he's out at a party with other
chicks
and then uh he bite dials his girlfriend
his girlfriend hears everything that
he's doing that [ __ ] wrote a
song about my life
i think he wrote about my life
you know just so why are you mad at him
yeah you should be mad at the girl yeah
why did you better be sure why he's like
why is it this this
somebody need to suck that big old dick
well hold on hold on make sure i didn't
do anything this is just not she could
have said no
this is not for me this is for every
average guy in america oh that's right
that's right you know average joe so i
had a show it's not even
you're the owner of average joe's jim
average joe's gym yes but how does she
know how does here's the thing she's
willing
to tell you let me tell you so i
couldn't tell i couldn't like let her
know that
i knew she was with him instead of our
girl so what i did was
i just kept playing his his music around
my girl the whole time
to see her yeah to like see the reaction
and i and
as of me playing his songs you think
you're trying to mind [ __ ] her but you
know what she's thinking about when
you're playing music she's singing
in my mouth she said she said she said
put that song over here
oh wow was your girlfriend asian wait
wait whoa
she's not like she's she wasn't on my
face
[Laughter]
she said she didn't she said it was he
had a condom now now here's the thing
um two things you should know about this
when i was playing his music i realized
trying to catch her in our lives i
realized his music wasn't all that
so that's why i'm giving the diss track
today is because i got to prove to him
like this is where rapping really is
oh yeah so go ahead are you
are you what's that talk to me are you
are you expecting a response
i'm not expecting anything like the
response is already there he's seen me i
see him now
now do you think you're gonna get uh
pure fire from this
from your ass for doing it what are you
hoping uh no i'm not
come on man i'm happy in a happy
relationship yeah i know that but do you
think that yeah she texts me today how
happy is the relationship that you got
to make a diss track about a dude that
guy
again that's what i'm trying to figure
out
i wasn't going to press it until i feel
like he was antagonizing me a little bit
oh with that outfit that outfit that's
when he's
i know you were thinking about it before
he did that oh he didn't i was listening
that you've been you've been sitting on
this for a long time
does it bother you that we like we know
he's back in heat you know what i'm
saying like we know his nickname
big sean came from from his size but
from
gold dick well here's the thing it's
well documented it's not well documented
because yeah ariana moved on so fast
that
you know let's just be honest i mean
dude she's with a real estate agent yeah
come on now yeah
let you know that big shine is poor
little sean no
shout out to shout out i want this well
documented i'm a big sean fan
i like being sean yeah me too also after
she did shawn she did pete davidson
who who she coined the term big dick
energy after
correct so she went from one big dick to
another big one hold on she never said
big dick with a big sean though
she never mentioned she never mentioned
it but we know his picture got leaked
yeah no we know
i like mine too i photoshopped
but it ain't a big one like sean's
listen we can call some of my past we
can call six figure
i'm i'm i'm pretty prove it i gotta
throw it
i got a third leg third leg why don't
you tiger this [ __ ] and start only
yeah that's what you should be doing
you're not making money off this diss
track oh yes i am
a bad idea do the diss track and be like
what's up man and then uh you go to my
onlyfans.com
you'll see what you're missing girl i
can i can't do that xbox
shout out to xbox uh i'm the you know
again super bowl commercial i can't show
you
the face of my face basically xbox well
maybe once that campaign's over we can
do it
yeah yeah well we get chan to be there
mess with the lighting and stuff for you
[Applause]
here's another thing another thing right
how what if this diss track gets a lot
of like buzz
and i become a rapper what if oh that'd
be sick and they're like touring but
then you got the pressure of like
your cardi b now what do you mean like
she wasn't ready to be a rap star so she
had a bunch of people writing her music
and [ __ ] she's like i guess i want to do
this so who wrote yours
again that's a great question again
little brows wait a little bit browser
right i told you i told you i played
this diss track right
can we i'm gonna sing you you wanna do
it no no
you have some inspiration i had some
inspiration listen i asked a little
brows like bro
i'm over my head right can you can you
give me something he sent back a whole
track and
you could just tell it was too much
rapper [ __ ] i was yeah you know what
i'm trying it was too deep i was like
you had over the head bars so me and you
should have asked jelly roll
well jelly roll was busy now now i i had
to see big shot from the side
why would you say you guys do look
similar no no one again
it's the it's the the haircut and the
like the way you you just shoot
you guys are both good looking dude yeah
well he looks like your little brother
he yeah he's he's my prototype you can
say something like that protegee
well should we just play the track and
then go from there all right let's just
play it it is your birthday guys ready
you're ready
29 years old no can we act like this as
a talent show and
uh yeah cat me and jebel just like
american idol right
all right you're the
uh randy randy come on dawg that's a
note for me dawg
and i'll be simon cowell okay okay okay
right right there you go look at it
before we play it can i just thank a lot
of people i want to thank y'all
like his family like just like they
don't get to do that american idol
because listen i told you i'm not on
board for this i'm a big sean fan yeah
again
i don't know if i support it but but if
it's good i'm going to give you your
money
i'm dropping
oh yeah i mean you know you're gonna
wrap it i'm gonna no no we're gonna play
this oh thank you
here we go no i'm just saying we want it
professionally done
all right
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
you hit my girl last summer and it left
me scar she was a hostess she was
working up at pm
it was busy too i can't believe you did
your best i was waiting outside for a
whole hour look through the window when
i saw you eating sweetie so i watched
[Music]
what the hell is going on what you mean
i mean you just going back and forth
about this big shot yes
what's up this is fire right yeah it was
fun to you man you get
you get your point he took my girl
anyway man
can we get back to the song man let's go
and do about that yeah you're right
y'all didn't believe me
holy [ __ ] now it got uh
it got a little detailed when you're
like you were again p.f
changs and y'all were in there and you
were the lettuce wraps and even the
mango i know right
when i was out i was outside my nissan
sentra
for an hour waiting you know
one thing about sally you should talk
one thing about rolly boy you got to get
it off your chest
yeah that's called get it off you feel
better now is that what you feel better
i feel great i feel uh i got it like
it's in the but not like
you got that out of the way yeah no i
can go back to being malik b yeah
yeah yeah yeah but i want to shout out
everyone that's like with me for the
ride all the fans
little sean you can go back to making
weak music and it's a matter of fact i
really like big sean i'm just going to
say that out loud oh i love it
oh you're just doing oh you're just yeah
yeah yeah yeah but you know what this is
with the judges let's go let's go simon
simon is all is at the end yeah let's go
to ryan seacrest go ahead
uh secret's the judge secrets doesn't
judge but since i do have a musical
background i'm not gonna lie i
unexpected
yeah he does he's the only one with the
me well chappelle knows me
about you know what i'm me and cat are
the only ones with a musical background
now i have some hidden pipes on me but
i'm not
getting pipes
carry on okay so we'll go we will go
with kevin should be my nickname
wait man i i got to say something though
yeah professional music background as
well
yeah professional yes professional paid
for my duties uh
i expected something to be way lamer
yeah the fact yeah the fact that it was
actually like funny and and like
the lyrics are great the stop you know
he stopped it pause it
went back in i gotta give you like a
solid eight thank you
and that's out of ten it's out of a
twenty
eight a ten eight at ten okay that's a
solid score that's just
from a from a guy and i by the way i
went all out with this this i was paid
for
i paid a lot of money when i heard it
i'm like i expected i
i envisioned how much time and energy
you put into it yeah that's what makes
this video i wrote it where was it
silver lake
all right also was very surprised
it sounds so much better than i thought
it would
and you're really good i think you're
better than a lot of soundcloud rappers
i've heard
i think you should go and take this
track put it on soundcloud and start
making like
comedic like fake disses to other people
like start off with justin timberlake
next see how that goes
well well that's good advice that's
great almost like
a little dicky yeah like because you're
not bad that's the thing you have good
flow
execution was great thank you thank you
well i try to i try to embody the
cadence of like a drake or
like uh oh i wasn't getting drake out
yeah i went yeah i wouldn't even throw
his name yeah
i didn't either yeah i did not get a
drink you get a drink without feeling
good
but feel
that's a great reference yeah damn can't
take this judging very soon
very good i'm surprised
i thought it was [ __ ] hilarious i
thought it was actually really funny
the flow was really good especially when
you like spread it was like man man
that was actually pretty dope but it is
it like it's comedically
it did crack me the [ __ ] up so yeah i do
get like a lonely island riffraff
like a little dicky like type vibes
where it just
can be it's just funny it's just funny
it's very you know
well but like but like as far as like
you know musically yeah
execution yeah the execution was great
what would you grade me
uh what would i get she didn't even give
you a grade yeah it was oh i'd give you
eight two
eight okay two weeks uh two eight
honestly
i i'll give you eight point five oh oh i
think you're gonna say ten
i thought i'd go ten i'd have to bring
you back down
we're all wrong
birthday is it we got pizza and everyone
have good vibes
uh yeah i was super surprised i thought
it was gonna be a complete [ __ ] show
um but it was really well done it's
professional and i thought it was
it was funny my favorite part was the
details of the pf changs
yeah yeah and then the eating sweet and
sour and then also a cameo by justin
whose
voice is hilarious yeah oh he's so funny
he's so funny
he should get into like animation like
cartoons or something seriously
you know at the top of the uh part of
like when he's we're doing the
introduction and you hear that
yeah that's his real laugh yeah he's so
funny can i tell you a funny story in
the studio
he shocked all of us like me and the
producer and uh my homeboy
and he was like justin do that laugh
again and he smokes justin smokes he was
like all right
do it just like that he goes
what we stopped he was like no just to
do it before he was like man i'm trying
i'm trying i'm crying
so stupid yeah i thought it was good
though that that was really good yeah
that's when you give them
it it was way it was way better than
like i said i thought it was gonna be so
trash i was like brothers i think eight
i think eight is fair
now listen i don't know if i put all my
energy in becoming a soundcloud rapper
i will i'm not but i don't know if
that's your future hold on we don't know
i mean xbox they
you know does that they do with xbox
well i told them i might be you know
they
only said they called so you think if if
xbox was picking you and big sean out of
a lineup
who do you think they're going to pick
well i already got like rapport with
them
well you know what we should do i mean
because kanye found big sean you know
his story
yeah he's a radio dj guy found him
mm-hmm
so maybe we could have kanye maybe
freestyle for kanye
passes you to good music i mean here's
the thing you [ __ ] on good music
but if connie called you up right now i
was like yo man you heard the diss track
we'll sign you right now
your dick would be so hard yeah and i
had to take a pill now now
i would i would freestyle i got to
freestyle right now if kanye called me
like say you kanye
all right i'm kanye on the spot
i'm wearing your shoes right now
everybody wears them hey listen
[Laughter]
i heard the diss track yeah the little
sign distraction yeah
okay yeah that's me this was my boy yeah
but we're looking for new talent on good
music
oh yeah i'm glad is he still on please
yeah no he's actually killing it uh what
do you got though
okay you want me to go right now yeah
just give me something because i gotta
i got [ __ ] to do okay okay i said joe
i said people want to have fun
like brendan when he had a man bun cat
she was stevie blue eyes but chinking
out the melodies like
get the vocal out of his eyes don't
squint just bit
chappelle you know me and anger
management issue yeah
yo what [ __ ] what you ruined it
your one audition what audition are you
[ __ ] trash one audition dog you
[ __ ] yeah that
that's a sign that you leave this where
it is okay
okay and i respect that yeah yeah you
did your thing bro it took me it's so i
don't want to become a rapper
it was so much but
you just know it's a lot of work like
like uh when people try to do comedy
well i was like talking i was talking to
schultz the other day after i watched a
special and i was like dude
you put in so much work into this you
can just tell the amount of [ __ ] work
that it took to pull something like this
off i can't
i mean i was exhausted watching i'm like
oh my god goes
you go and there's a joke at the joke
the picture like just the amount of work
you know because
i mean yeah it's all information it's
all like got to be like accurate
information that he's like
dropping as well i mean there's a lot
there's just so much to it
yeah yeah man i'm done well i'm just
gonna put it on like uh
all platforms and just yeah it'd be cool
yeah it's over with yeah
it's always always stop moving move on
yeah exactly where'd you get that fire
jersey i can't stop looking
oh he's from detroit yeah exactly so and
also oh
yeah i i can't prepare i don't know if
y'all picking up the queues i'm putting
down
and i got the yeezy's on who he signed
to yeah come
are there sweats from detroit or
something well this the swiss is nothing
you stay in sweats i do stay in sweats i
want to be comfortable with that you
don't need
this rolly boy it's rolly boyz this
sweats is rolling bruh he wears sweats
in the summer time too
uh i i i only wear jeans and so i don't
it's not it's rare i wear shorts
i'm sorry is it is it freestyle friday
you don't say like why are you in shorts
i don't know i it's i i never like
getting free stuff
right what is
you know i used to roast brian all the
time for wearing [ __ ] sandals with
jeans yeah
why are your toes it was thong sandals
it wasn't even like
yeah i've worn sweats once on this show
yes it went with the outfit but other
than that i won't leave the house in
sweat
yeah i just think it's more comfortable
it's like more laid back it fits
everyone's style but you're but you're
not wearing like
[ __ ] sweats that you lounge around in
the house those are like
fashions like this it's different yeah
exactly
so you know why i hung out with danny
ricardo yesterday do you know who he is
he's uh he's a formula one uh uh race
car driver
okay but he's uh he's uh hey [ __ ] you
how funny is that so stupid yeah
but he uh danny is uh he's a formula one
race card right if you know formula one
it's like
huge huge oh that's the guy right he's
like top five in the world so just the
way it works
uh just the way it works is so in all
the world so
like formula one racing is huge it's not
huge in america but international
that's what your brother loves right he
loves it but internationally it's
[ __ ]
huge it's kind of like sock you know
here it's not really that big
everywhere else it's [ __ ] popping
yeah that's how formula one is like
around the world it's so big
so like danny can walk around elaine
doesn't get disturbed here really like a
few people might
but if he's in australia or anywhere
else in the world he's tom cruise
really like super super fans that's
insane here's what's inside
because i don't know much about it's my
brother's world i don't know much about
it dude
out of all the race the millions of
racers in the world who start when
they're like seven you gotta start
really young to get involved in it
out of all the races in the world
there's only 20 spots
in the world to compete twenty
twenty at his level so twenty he's
thirty one okay or thirty there's only
twenty spots in the entire world to get
on the
circuit so think of any other sport
think of basketball
if there was only 20 spots yeah think of
the ufc if you could only have
20 fighters think how [ __ ] good those
20 guys are your elite
dude think about it it's nuts and the
money's really good they're
stupid big boy money because big boy
because of the sponsors correct
well and you it's like you know it's
like you're talking about red bull
ferrari yeah yeah mercedes rolex like
you guys know who
luke roloff oh yeah you know who lewis
hamilton is right he's probably the most
famous one yeah
that's like his like the guy he races
against i like his hair yeah
yeah but it's not dude and but then also
you know how like we'll go on tour and
then if we want to break we can take a
break
yeah dude their year they're like they
see like ufc fighters their season and
but it's
he's flying like he's telling me he has
a schedule where he goes like
i forget what it is it's like japan
thailand
russia and it's all in three weeks are
you kidding me they wanted to just fly
all over and then he'll be in like dubai
they're gonna shoot over to london
then a flight to austin like they're
just on tour non-fucking stuff
[ __ ] and it's yearly yeah year round
damn now you're
and they have to wait i think used to i
don't know any of this it's crazy to me
you have to weigh under i think it's 153
pounds because
every every like everything matters it's
not hard yeah so
you know they'll spend millions of
dollars for technology to make the car
two pounds lighter
so if you're the race car driver they're
like dude you got to stay under
it's going to help us not spend money on
the car if you can just come in two
pounds lighter
but it's not so it's a whole system now
nuts
you can you can because you love fast
cars love them
so would you ever like i know you can't
professionally race but would you ever
like get on the track and try to push
like two i'd be down for that yeah i'd
be done for that you would be i'd be
i'd be down to get on the track i don't
want to do it with my car though i don't
want to [ __ ] up it's hard on the car
like the tires yeah in my car i'd be
down to do it like you know
like danny's with uh mclaren so any
town he goes to mclaren sends him a
brand new car are you kidding me while
he's there he's
like oh yeah he's there yeah yeah while
he's there he's driving mclaren as [ __ ]
i think it's tight that it's like that
tough though i like [ __ ] oh dude
and you talking things that are like
that tough yeah he's like he's like i
started at nine
yeah and then lewis hampton started when
he's like five yeah
and what's nuts is lewis hampton story's
dope because
obviously not a lot of black guys in
racing right and he grew up i think in
uh
england but um it's so it's so expensive
to get involved in racing for
when you're a kid because you got to buy
your car yeah and then you gotta
remember you got to
travel with it to all these circuits
yeah it's not like you know soccer you
just need a pair of [ __ ] clothes oh
yeah
football you just need your gear
basketball you just gotta show up with
some kicks
but if your kid's involved with this
[ __ ] yeah you gotta pay to get in you
gotta pay for the car
you got a helmet safety all so it's
really expensive so lewis hamilton's dad
but i think he had three jobs and told
his son he's like i'm going to pay for
this but you got to [ __ ] win
so he won every single race
because he felt the pressure of his dad
was like dude i'm busting my ass
you bust your ass bro see that's just
that's something that i like
dude just bawling all the time and then
danny's dad
was uh a really good racer too growing
up like he was a racer
and like he got him into it and then he
told his dad he wants to race
like all right let's do it and then just
go on the car and then danny you know
you know you could argue that he's more
talented than anybody because his
car mclaren's gonna be different i know
i'm speaking on turnout because i don't
know exactly but
yeah he like mercedes like who lewis
hamilton raised him in his
yeah who lewis hamilton races for he has
the fastest
he has the best car like his car is
better than danny's
but and danny has a worse car but he'll
finish like third or seconds yeah
because just because he's a better
driver it but if you put him
this way it's crazy if you put him in
those other cars he's finishing first
every [ __ ] time
[ __ ] and you would never know like he's
such a humble like
yeah just well grounded yeah and the
amount of money that dude i mean
dude but just is it great yeah what's
the kind of money in that
it gotta it has to be a lot all the time
so like so
similar to probably uh star mba money so
per year like you're talking about
i would assume just off salary
endorsements
um but and but that doesn't mean so
lewis hampton made 40 million
so he made 10 but that's just based off
of the salary that they paid
i get what you're saying yeah but
endorsements if he finishes no
endorsements
no homeboys are balling so remember
there's only 20 spots
now got it but so when you so like i
guess like with the nba like okay you
you sign your rookie you sign with the
clippers
and they go this is what you're going to
make so that's the same thing with this
yes
it's not based on like you gotta win
races to make money he was telling me
like it just depends like you can do
like
less salary and more incentives
or you can do just a high salary and you
don't get any incentive so if you win
first it doesn't matter you get this
flat salary
i mean obviously the salaries are huge
anyway yeah yeah but you can do all
right i'll take a little less and
banking myself
getting the pole position or first
second or third place
but it's nuts dude that's [ __ ] 20
spots
that's a perfect example and a story is
like be selfish with your
time so you can be generous with your
money later like his dad was like yo i'm
busting my ass
you better brush your ass so you just
imagine growing up as a kid you selfish
no distractions i gotta get it and then
like now he's enjoying the fruits of his
yeah his labor i know that's what i
think is like really [ __ ] 20 spots
oh dude i love i love i love that it's
like almost 20 seconds
you're a good dude i love this yeah such
a good person because
what's the what's the percentage for ufc
for people to make it
in the ufc oh man not not great it's
it's very small percentage
right yeah i like [ __ ] like that what do
you do yeah i like that i like people
[ __ ] comedy everybody just [ __ ]
tries to
well but so there's a difference between
trying like i'm sure there's a lot of
people that race cars i see what you're
saying there's a huge difference between
trying it then make an actual living
doing it yeah like you know less than
i think it's 0.01 of actual
actors make a living acting yeah it's
like 0.1
or some [ __ ] like but you get i mean i
think with with with uh with comedy and
like what we do you get a lot of people
more people that complain to be
somewhere like you you i don't think you
can go complain
to [ __ ] dana white like and you and
like it's people that aren't even that
good but they think they're better than
what they are and they complain he deals
with that all the time oh he does
they do so so that like why aren't i the
main event i should be getting this
money
oh really okay dude because the numbers
like we're a numbers game so
we know you sell this main pay-per-view
so that's why we're paying you this much
and they think they deserve this much so
he deals with that all the time
so dope about racing is like like not a
like
town to speak yeah talent so
that's what i'm trying to say think if
there's only 20 spots in comedy
there's only 20 people who could
headline around the world oh my god it's
[ __ ] nice
like when you told me 20 i'm like what
the [ __ ] but also think about that at
the same time
think about the big headliners and i
mean i mean i guess we have a
good amount like that are making like
big time headliners
you know i think we yeah i guess we have
a good amount you're gonna make it right
but yeah but like if it was just 20 20.
[ __ ]
whoa i was looking
like i'm so proud of you man i don't
know that well i don't know like yeah
you just heard it yeah
i was like what the [ __ ] damn but that's
what any sport like look it's only 30
so look at some uh what a lot of making
you see uh less than one percent of of
the planet are born to become fighters
and one percent of these fighters go on
to become ufc fighters damn one percent
and one percent so so that then that's
one percent of
fighters yeah yeah so think of the
percentage of people that want to be
professional fighters and out of those
professional fighters
one percent make it to the ufc what is
it for like uh college going into
the nba uh impossible oh it is
impossible
how are you on season five or have you
gotten to where ovi comes in the big
basketball player die me yeah i looked
at my girl my goddamn
good looking dude he played but he's
from london what's this
can you remember one basketball mba
right
yeah nba one point two percent oh only
everything's
everything is about one percent your
chance of doing that but
but like you know when you got started
in comedy
if so if you're like hey i wanna be a uh
i wanna do stand-up comedy
if someone came up to you as i came in
so here's the odds of you making it
and you'd be like oh one percent i don't
wanna deal with that yeah you're never
anybody who makes it me i'm different
though i'll be like okay let's take it
on
i don't i don't give a [ __ ] i don't care
about odds or anything yeah yeah i'm
like okay
yeah they're cool okay it doesn't matter
yeah yeah that's what i like about it
you know cause like yeah those guys
could have done that too like only 20
[ __ ]
make it in [ __ ] but like but you know
you gotta i mean
you could be that 20. that's the thing
you could be that 20. oh yeah
that's the [ __ ] that's what i i don't
know i just love me too hard work [ __ ]
like you gotta you gotta believe in
yourself
execute and just you know and then and
then think about
uh thanks tony uh robbins but think
about uh
saudi arabia would you listen to the
[ __ ] i know alex is like subtle like
[ __ ] positive he's like if you
believe he can achieve
and then i kept talking about things you
got to be selfish with the time you
gotta be selling your time like all
right that has nothing to do with
uh my boy danny ricardo but we will
power to do this why don't we just sit
there
he's like every dream every dream starts
with a challenge i'm like all right gary
v
shut it down dude i hate that
motivational [ __ ]
i hate it i hate it you hate that kind
of stuff i hate it
i thought you related to it more
chappelle because you
like i read the self-help books but like
i don't know it's self-help it's
different it's not telling you like
yeah like i take it for myself i'm not
sitting here like
yo you you could be this you could be
yeah but i don't know
yours like to motivate like but you're
not really like gary vee [ __ ] are you no
i never read this [ __ ] no
the [ __ ] i i like to read is like how to
just like be a better person be a better
person and take on your own [ __ ] like
whole responsibility
for yourself ownership that's what
that's what i read like i like to read
[ __ ] like that like
it makes it all about you it's not about
like this you know put your mind to it
like i can't i cannot
i hate getting into that [ __ ] because
it's so cliche it's so obvious
you got another one your transgressions
it's like triggering it's like just get
it done
yeah can i that's how i make sure well
i'm sorry what
motivates you brenden not now i'm just
asking because you say you know
like i can't even tell you you're like
if someone cuz you have great drive i've
been around you with your [ __ ]
yeah you work your
i feel like they do that'd be a weird
thing to be like
your [ __ ] brittany i gotta do it
sells out everything
i'm
like i always think of it like this it's
like like with religion i'm not
religious
like if religion is that thing that
helps you yeah stay grounded for
yourself
then [ __ ] do it yeah you know don't
push it on me yeah don't push it do it
yeah but [ __ ] [ __ ] do it i'm not
religious yeah you know but i'm not
against it yeah i don't even
know who you are what person like your
spirituality is per it's like perfect
that you don't have you don't care about
the outside noise because you know who
you are you in tune with yourself you're
a sagittarius
you say sagittarius
but you know you don't have an idea of
like what just [ __ ] drives you just
yeah i know yeah i think you just have
it i i think so
i've had this [ __ ] fired me since i
was a kid
yeah like since i was a kid i always
felt different
i don't know what it is in your nature
yeah it's just like i i run hot and
yeah in my heart did you ever get
overlooked overlooking anything oh yeah
oh so that's big time chips like this
yeah
yeah just on your shoulders there's a
[ __ ] pile of pringles on my shoulder
really ton kettle chips and it started
ever since i was
like when i was younger started from
when i was on this like
i got into this like high level like uh
aaa basketball team like this big league
basketball team and i was the only white
guy on the team
yeah and yeah it's not racist
like the coach treated me like [ __ ] yeah
and i remember we all got
like we said like they we raised all
this money for new jerseys yeah and he
gave everybody jerseys except for me
and he yeah what and i have to wear my
old jersey while all my friends got
their new jerseys and i just who
pisses me off to this i know right i
feel it right now i'm looking at her
right now
no wait why did he so that's what i said
that's that's also why i'm a like uh
yeah just but ever since i was little
like always like those little things
like
jerseys and logos and like colors like i
was really into like fashion
yeah so that meant like it hurt my
feelings so bad so yeah
i was different but then there's that
and then
like in high school football like
finally when it was my time my senior
year
the first play of the season um we went
down to florida to play
and they it there's the the cornerback
was had a full ride to florida state
and i was looking to go somewhere big
like texas a m or cu
or uh cal like i was gonna go somewhere
big i was like i'm gonna start just
[ __ ] dude florida state watch this
so the coach called the first play a
deep pass to me
and that [ __ ] florida state player
picked the ball off
first play picked the ball off and i was
chasing him down to
i was going to strip him like all right
you got the ball behind the strip it's
going to be dope
and he juked out our biggest defender
gary gary moore who was like
6-7 350 pounds he juked him out and gary
missed
and ran into me and uh broke my ribs and
lacerated my liver
so i missed my entire senior year season
[ __ ]
so i had to go to a smaller college work
my ass off there and then go to division
one
yeah as a walk-on and then i was as
talented
i thought as the rest of the scholarship
players but they treated me like [ __ ]
so same thing we were a nike school and
they would give
all the top players special shoes yeah
that's why i care so much about shoes
yeah they give all the top players
special shoes that never gave them to me
really but but but why though like it's
just like because i wasn't
i wasn't bobby purify or lawrence
vickers i wasn't a scholarship at the
time
so you had to work for everything you
know you worked for they still
overlooked everything and then balled
out senior balled out thought i was
gonna get drafted
got overlooked there so it's like these
chips i get to the ufc
you know so it's just overlooked weird
man but you don't seem like you have a
chip on your shoulder
no i don't like i'm not like i don't
look at other like
comics or like podcasts like i have no
it's just different with that
i just worry about my [ __ ] because you i
mean especially in our world like you
can see the chips heavy
yeah the people that have like no not
with you
their chips are different their chips
are they're not successful and they look
at other people
and blame their failures on other people
because they think yeah or you're taking
or not
like you're taking something from them
and that's their problem oh
that's the reason why i've had some
comics say some crazy [ __ ] to me yeah
right
like i've had comments oh you only get
that because you're black not even
because they don't even
not even that i'm talented me too
because you're black that's the like
that's the [ __ ] like
but like you know that that stuff is oh
that that's that's never gonna like
yeah i would get for the not too much
now i'd get oh the only reason
he sells tickets because he fought in
the ufc listen i wasn't
i wasn't knowing you'll i don't think so
anymore no no one's coming
you still had to work hard to sell
tickets you weren't selling tickets
immediately were you [ __ ] no
exactly so that's the the no you
constantly have to beat that narrative
like oh it's it's just uh
like a [ __ ] charlie sheen tiger blood
tour where you're yeah you know it's
just this kind of
act you know yeah like you couldn't go
back into a city and sell tickets if you
weren't funny i remember i remember when
uh when stevo was on here he said he
didn't sell tickets immediately
and he was already [ __ ] super he's
already stevo you know what i mean like
he's already
everybody he really doesn't work like
that that's what people don't understand
it doesn't work like that you can't just
sell the tickets just all the
justification of you've already had this
like name no you know like i couldn't go
to the if
if i didn't have some sort of talent and
comedy i couldn't get up at the comedy
store
exactly it would happen once and like
get the [ __ ] out like
the standard they're so high mm-hmm yeah
yeah yeah i was i was a little different
though like i mean i think what drove me
was like uh
i don't know i think i just don't want
to be a loser yeah
kids that's especially now you got kids
yeah don't there's nothing worse when
you're running
like an old friend like we're doing man
just and you tell you like god [ __ ]
and you just feel bad like you stopped
man you stopped the [ __ ] race
like it never stops exactly it never
stops it's like a [ __ ]
constant you you would you have a drive
yeah i wasn't
the i was wasn't the most talented guy
in my neighborhood
like it was so many people that was more
talented
as far as rapping
would you say what did you say do you
want me to cry again
god dude he's all you gotta
[Applause]
you wake up from the moon you land on
some stars you know
every day you wake up in the morning you
look yourself in the mirror and say i am
somebody
all right kids one thing about me that
we know is i
stay on that kratom i stay on it chin
stays on it there's
a reason why i haven't pushed on you
guys because you got to trust
the kratom that you take and this
company
is a company that i trust it's a product
that i use
every dang day and finally we partnered
up
and here we are man we're talking about
that super leaf
kratom man if you've never heard of
kratom it's a herbal supplement kind of
like cbd
but instead of coming from a cannabis
plant it's from something closer like a
coffee tree
people use kratom every day your boy
when i go on stage
podcasts working out ride my bike among
that kratom sun
uh energy support uh some people will
substitute for coffee or pre-workout
listen i'll take the pre-workout and
coffee on top of kratom because i got
problems
some people use it to manage stress
there's different strains which some
chili out
some give you energy whatever you're
looking for they got you
covered all right and uh listen
the super leaf keeps kratom the way
nature intended it to be
there's no games no gimmicks it's
reliable
they have it uh tested through uh out a
third party source
so you know it's super legit all right
so if you want to try some kratom and
get 20
off go to getsuperleaf.com that's get
super leaf that's super lef
dot com enter the promo code fighter for
20
off that's getsuperleaf.com promo code
fighter
listen some of y'all harry out there and
there's no reason
for it so get to harry's dot com slash
fighter everything you need starts at
just
three bucks what are you looking for man
how about you get freaking razors from a
factory in germany
they're the sharpest best razors you can
get they got new razors harry's is
delivering the sharpest shave ever
and they're raising the prices their new
blades are so sharp that guys who
normally shave four times a week i was
like you know what we're just doing it
once a week now all right cool man also
quality guaranteed they confidently
stand by their blades with 100 money
back guaranteed
on harrys.com harry's available wherever
you shop
right harry's has a great offer for you
guys new
us of a customers can redeem harry's
trial set at harry's dot com
slash fighter for just three bucks you
get a five blade razor all right
a weighted handle foaming shave gel and
a travel cover to protect your blade
when you're on the go just go to harry's
dot com slash fighter
and redeem your trial offer today ask
him one simple question he just drops
[ __ ]
positive quote god
you know every day you wake up in the
morning you look yourself in the mirror
and say i am somebody well i i
remember when i when i first met you the
reason why i [ __ ] with you
i was like this guy [ __ ] works man
this guy oh this guy's just out there
like
thank you you didn't care like what mike
you and a lot of times you know
people always say this man you know what
i didn't [ __ ] with malik right off the
i thought brian was bringing on the road
to hold mitts for him and then just had
you open because brian's had some shitty
openers
he's just you know he's always had
shitty open so i figured he was bringing
on the road and like oh he's just
holding mitts for him because i
i've never saw you around the economy oh
yeah yeah i was like what the [ __ ] and
then when we did houston i'm like oh
[ __ ]
yeah yeah he was brian was like a big
push for me to
move to uh oh yeah la yeah he uh
he let me do a guest spot for him back
home in phoenix and it was his first
time seeing me do stand up
and he just i remember he ran backstage
because he watched me he ran backstage
and he was like
he goes you need to get out of here yep
you got to get out of arizona do you
know you know brian bought uh
carmichael his first car he never he
never have a car yeah
and every time you tell me the story
gerard carmichael jerome carmichael oh
got it
who's like you know obviously super
italian guy when brian first met him he
didn't have a car and he's like
taking a bus from us san diego and
brian's like oh we can't have that brian
bought him
his first car never he never he's like
bro don't like
don't tell anyone that story he never
wanted to boast like even my old
other friend like uh me and him like you
know my i won't say his name but brian
helped him out with rent bought him a
car oh yeah and just like and just like
yo he did so much for that guy but
he but he believes in hard work and like
if you got it you got it the other guy
was just kind of lazy
yeah and he like wanted brian to keep
spool feeding him and that's
one thing i will not put up with you
guys it's lazy yeah yeah lazy
all the time like don't get comfortable
dude yeah you know what i'm saying do i
look comfortable to you
nope i hope not oh you can't you came in
that santa claus outfit i don't know
that oh that wasn't comfortable in that
[ __ ] suit
you could say you see me just kidding
just kidding sweetheart
ever since i moved to my new spot i
haven't had a chance to like you know
really like get settled into the house
because we just been
we just literally been going non-stop so
like
this past couple weeks is like the first
time we've been able to sit down and so
her and i did our first i think it was
our first time doing a target run
together it's so fun
it was nice target's fantastic
target is my son's favorite great day
that was my second date with me and my
queen
dude i'll tell you right now there are
some baddies roaming around targets oh
people say whole foods dude [ __ ] whole
foods if you're single go to target
well it's hard my mom calls it tarjay go
to target call me target as well
uh she say santiago but look um
is she from l.a nah she's from ohio
um they would say something like that
yeah someday but i respect it but but
target now am i the only one you go in
there for something that you need
but you always come out with [ __ ] their
stuff is fantastic oh dude they have so
many so many deals
so many sales i'm like yo i came in
there for napkins i swear to god i went
in there for napkins i bought a new
iphone
yeah iphone charger iphone's at target
yeah yeah they got some dope graphic
tees all the time
they do as far as the toy section for
kids like there's no toy stores
besides target where do you go for toys
like i don't know
toys r us is shut down oh that's a great
amazon and it also
are is gamestop still around yeah it's
still around barely
barely everything individual
game stop stores but for the most part
everyone gets their games online
you just stream it online you just buy
it and it's all there yeah
which is kind of a shame there's nothing
better than going to the [ __ ] game
picking up that game i'd rather get it
delivered to me
you what i like the physical i like it's
fun picking it out
yeah they do that now yeah are you
seeing little [ __ ] robots
why are you getting mad sorry that was
aggressive dog i saw one of the rope
before posters there's people
there's people yeah yeah there's people
buying them you got to type in yeah
everybody [ __ ] is all everybody i
mean if you're a postmates guy like
all right dude you got another maybe two
years two maybe before these things are
just
dropping [ __ ] off you know what's so
crazy i'm like how are we so comfortable
with that
i'm just like cause they're not gonna
eat your food chapelle i know they're
not gonna eat my food but what if a
[ __ ] [ __ ] with that
what do you mean they don't they don't
[ __ ] with it they don't [ __ ] with it
they have a strategy
security strike yeah exactly like a
homeless dude can't jack and like get
into it
but yes but they have these these uh all
in west hollywood
uh following behind it yeah it's west
hollywood that's probably mine
no dude there's one by my house what the
[ __ ] does this mean so yeah like you
gotta type in your uh
you're nuts yeah i just feel so bad for
it it seems like a little kid to me
what that's why it's like a little kid
walking down the street by itself and
they stopped seeing this little robe
bottom like hey yeah
yeah bro literally uh we ordered from
moomoo
no no moo right and we stay on what is
that
no no no no
not no boot there's no move no bull no
nobody got time for vegan food are you
seriously
you guys like with is your girl vegan no
she's not but we [ __ ] with it
why because we want to be healthy it's
not bad oh come on
you don't [ __ ] with vegan food never i
feel like you're trolling us right now i
know right
never i sort of got oh really never why
you don't you never done like a
plant-based diet no have you
no i know we twins with food
yeah i don't know my side you get
yourself i see you guys picture
like that chick-fil-a i had chick-fil-a
[ __ ] twice this
you saw my salad yep i ain't [ __ ]
around stevie told you a little too
heavy on the dressing
it was a little too heavy hey you're
trying you're trying hey do you know
what i would have sent before
all right [ __ ] three chick-fil-a
sandwiches
oh my gosh i wanted to eat chick-fil-a
so bad last night what happened why
didn't you i
[ __ ] held my ground and i got that
salad because you knew they were gonna
have pizza today
in that and i got the salad guess what
they forgot the dressing i still ate
that
it was good nothing worse nothing worse
no
yeah bro you got to go with them like
when you say you get your sushi they
forget your [ __ ]
uh bro what did they forget the ginger
i'm like yeah yeah might as well not
bring it
don't bring it right oh dude
or if you get nuggets from chick-fil-a
and they forget the barbecue i'm like
i can't eat these no i don't bring them
over if you forget it don't break it
yeah don't bring it i'd rather you not
[ __ ]
yeah i'll still tell you dude there's
nothing i'll tip you to not bring it
dude there is
nothing better to me than after i put my
kids to bed because it's
when i get home it's non-fucking stop
they go to bed at seven
then we order some good food and we put
on [ __ ] love island
it is living right you're chilling
you're your own dude i eat my dinner i
watch love island and then i
pour a nice [ __ ] uh glass of whiskey
a nice whiskey yeah
oh i i i did have a scoop of ice cream
uh from where
uh the blue bell okay you ever hear that
yep that's the brand wait it's not a is
it a spot
no i uh i post made it oh okay don't
judge me
huh no joke nothing no judge here
nothing was that
i tried four dollars an ice cream the
other day oh blue
wait what yep from uh yeah
jenny's jenny's mint chocolate chip
jenny's this one by the way
it's so good oh you've never had it
before i've never had it until last
night it's so good what is it called
jesus chinese ice cream so salt and
straw is my favorite jenny's is
close second uh pull up ginny's bluebell
that stands yeah that's why i'm
yeah that's my friend that's that's
standard jenny's jenny's or
salt and straw bro saul straws right by
my house
is there something strawberry yeah a
large one you never had something strong
i never had it either yeah i've had it
oh okay
well because it wasn't open wasn't open
jenny's is ridiculous
what's your favorite flavor
i like the whiskey pecan whiskey
uh i love their uh coffee it's
intelligent
the coffee is really good i like the
peanut butter with the freckled
chocolate i really hate about it i know
is it weird
is it where i where i live by no no no
no
that's a big area okay i do live in
downtown which is
yeah tastes like very big drake i know
right yeah
i'm walking around with a [ __ ] i
actually don't think anyone's gonna come
and roll up on you yeah don't worry
well home is i'll tell you what though
now that i got a ring and i got
it out that i asked that i i got it i
got a ring
so and you can look at the the
neighborhood yeah and everybody's right
now everybody's packages are getting
stolen
so as soon as you get a package we gotta
run out there and grab it because the
holidays there's just thieves
they don't put it in your gate they do
but dudes jump over
it's weird man yeah you gotta be on it
amazon amazon but you're so dope about
amazon they take a picture like hey it's
here
and then they just like that's just that
then they'll have liability yeah like we
dropped it off it's on you now
i just bought a order it looks solid
like some [ __ ] put out on the on the
neighborhood watch
was like he blew this this guy took my
package at three in the morning
i looked at the comments everyone's like
why the [ __ ] would you leave your
package out there at three in the
morning
that's what you get [ __ ] that's what
you get yes
i'm in a gate i'm in a gated area as
well
just checking the package that's coming
to your house again burn yeah those are
big ones
yeah i do it i'm like studio equipment
someone's gonna hit the lottery they
jack those
still out for delivery slices so it's
gonna be like whoa
whoa well yeah should they drop these
off this morning i had no [ __ ] clue
oh listen
talk to them about it man i'm jealous
right now but tell them i'm jealous no
they call those the the
motor falcon baseball gloves no dog
these are the bodegas i always say that
because he says it all the [ __ ] dog
was wearing did you call him oh he's
wearing the sakai is
chin the one the one with the black and
white oh yeah see how they have a real
big
right yeah look at this you gotta wear
them with certain jeans man
oh you look like you you look like you
ride the short bus
that's a japanese collab chin those are
like huge sukkai's huge they're
expensive yeah
yeah um dope ass kick though you gotta
be real
careful what jeans you want i feel like
i need another pair of jordans
yeah i'm feeling like it's coming off i
hate that i'm feeling it yes nikki
oh your vans right here my vans are
right there and they're going thing
going nowhere
is that like i'm feeling it man you
thinking
more ones i like the one there's these
ones i do like the ones those are
there's these ones that are like uh
white and brown
travis oh the ones i have the mochas is
that what it is
well what is the is that nike signed
backwards on it yeah
uh jordan mochas yeah yeah i got those
yeah those came out
you know we got uh uh shoe of the year
the brand
can you guess let me guess someone you
in here guess what got shoe of the
[ __ ] year okay hold on wait those are
the ones you like
i like those don't say don't say shoe of
the year or brand of the
uh brand that like yeah like best don't
say new balance
new balance by a landslide are you
serious isn't that some [ __ ] kawhi
is like such it's not even quite it's
like all the collabs they did all the
shoes they dropped
away bruh all right is that weirdo and
jay loves new balances so does uh
schultz schultz you know who else loves
new balance white mike white turner it's
a certain
level it's a certain demo that [ __ ]
with new balance yeah i've like i have a
grateful dead new balances that i wear a
lot but man
you know that's not your first pick dude
nike i told you
reebok came to me years ago and they had
a deal like but you gotta only wear
reebok went you said no this ain't
happening
really i feel like it makes me
physically ill
to just wear reebok i actually can't
even picture you you know i can't do it
you wouldn't even copy iverson no nope i
love nike
uh well i'm only people i know like like
section or this though like new balances
yes
washington dc they they're big out there
yeah well in new york new balance is
huge baltimore
oh so it's a fascist thing it started
but now it's big man new balance is big
really what is this weird like if you go
it might be on dope new balance type in
a shoe brand of the year
it might be a complex article but
i don't i just don't [ __ ] with them
you think pumas i can never wear those
the easy yeah i'm good with the jordan
ones and fours
i like the fours there's these other
travis scott ones that i like they're
blue
i don't know which oh i have the those
are the fives those are fives those are
dope
i got those those are the first scots i
got oh dude those are hard to get huh
yeah i'm sure we can figure it out which
ones which ones
the the blue traps got these blue yeah
oh cactus jack
fives from the north carolina blue yeah
right oh yeah have you
seen the friends and family package yes
i've seen their purples yes i've seen it
i like those man i wish i was his friend
or family put the order in
also i got some new slip-on vans on the
way so slippies
oh your boy uh dan danny uh danny
no the the [ __ ] 411 driver he
rode his bike yesterday in advance i
thought of you oh really he didn't yeah
you can do this in the vans like that
he's worth millions of dollars that's
kind of disrespectful
he's modest just saying nike dunk is the
2020 shoe of the year
no he said brandon i know but uh
companies in the world are nike adidas
new balance
um pull up those travis scott
fives yeah those are those are dope i
like those
also do we know how do they gotta be so
hard to get
do you know how easy it is to get vans
there's a reason [ __ ] so easy
well i'm just saying are these the
watchpan
i like those those are stitches don't
get the same i have the i like those
those uh
the blues those blue ones nope that's
what i like
yes those are my favorite colors blue i
got those those are beautiful
you got those damn we shall you and you
got them
yeah we shall well when i try to get
them we shall wear them one day what are
your
sizes i i wear 12 12 i wear 11 11
yeah so we could all fit yeah we can all
i can fit all those
oh you can up to 13 yeah well you wear
11 through 13.
well i could obviously fit 11 and 12. 13
is my biggest size
oh got it yeah good playground some
shoes i don't know how those shoes run
do you like because you scored are you
able to get 13s for all of them or do
you have to run
i get 13 yeah if 13. because these
i got these i got these guavas these are
twelves they but they're tight they're a
little tight
i probably should've went twelve and a
half but the ones fit
so perfect and those are twelves i would
probably get a
13 in those travis if you were me yep
are you serious well you can't try mine
on
see if okay yeah that's right let's not
just get the smaller shots yeah do we
know who like make these like
posts like who's the best sneakers like
who do they have come from like legit
like i just sent chin the article
but see new balances they've they've
done all these collabs you don't want
those
i'd wear those those miamis those those
are dope those are hard
look at those dior but so that's the top
of the list on this one right
yeah but hypebeast is pretty legit but i
thought hypebeast
had uh some articles there's nike right
there those diors were so impossible to
get i couldn't call they are
how much i know how much girls run bro
what 12 grand
bro 12 grand not doing it dude i gotta
they're like dude they're spoken for
like what i couldn't get them
they'll come out for four months i'm
hitting you up now he's like dude
they're spoken for him like [ __ ]
what does that mean right like they
already can't like everyone they're
already taken
like there's no they them to like huge
celebrities or whatever like drake like
drake gets them first yeah
really yeah and they're not gonna hit
you up they're not giving comedians
podcasts
okay there it is i saw that
i don't think i'm gonna get addicted i
probably won't get addicted to this shoe
thing
i won't get addicted but uh it is nice
to have like some
pretty cool shoes you know eat some dope
kicks you know but i
i'm not going to get addicted is it it's
not a bad addiction
uh that's all you're spending within
your means i don't think it's bad yeah
there you go
don't you spend within your money yeah
within your means don't live above your
means because
that means that you're not being real
with who you are as a person like like
one pair of monkeys
i powered things but like
i'm not bad
you know who got the uh dior's and got
them ruined
billy eilish she got the high tops and
the low tops oh
[ __ ] yeah she's [ __ ] all over it yeah i
guess her dog had like diarrhea one day
and chat all over her shoes nothing
about the dior's
there's a bunch of fakes out there so i
had a uh my girl's friend was like hey i
know brent's in the shoes
i have these i'm like man how much she
told me like this
i don't know man it's all 300 bucks dog
yeah she's like oh
she was like 600 i'm like even 600 like
you just flip those and make
buy something to me you make 10 g's off
that like what yeah
so you gotta be careful man yeah cause
so so the fakes
are you still you're still making money
off the fakes
yeah it just depends it depends there's
a lot of fakies out there like they just
seized an entire shipment off the the
[ __ ] border here oh a ton from china
yeah
they sees it like thousands of fake
nikes
that they're and they were selling them
for the actual price yeah but here you
know here's what's tricky
is how do they get a lot of those fakes
come from the same
factories so some of them although
they're not
technically nike they're still produced
by the the same
the same material the same people make
them but they're not
actual you know what i'm saying they
don't come from the nike
like you know what i'm saying like
they're they're the same factory yeah
they're exactly the same
but there's just some slightly off not
even off like they might just be
just not certified because they're not
certified through the nike
but then so nike has to certify all
these oh yeah they have to go through
there's a whole thing
there's a whole thing but but here's
these are easy but here's here
here's what's here's what there's some
vans they get crazy pictures
like the toys like the toy story fans
insane
toy story tourist toy story has van yeah
like my son you know the sam the
the woody uh toy story uh reeboks
for christmas yeah uh
toy story vans they're expensive they
are super expensive there's some
exclusive vans that get really pricey
dog
damn thousands of dollars any of these
the buzz light the peanut butter [ __ ]
buzz
those vans old school toy story woody's
ones see that's 369. and that's for
those
that's the lowest price on stock yeah no
the far
left
damn i click on the challenge i had to
go to those uh stockx to get those
kendricks so the high order
the lowest ask is 369. yeah the highest
bid is 90
nobody bidding on that at a 10 out of 10
though
yeah shoes are weird yeah that's i mean
it's a lot i mean
i would like one more pair that i'm done
i said that
you said that i said that three years
ago but but here's the thing i have
great willpower
drinking cold turkey i know yeah i i
think about
stopping the drink for january oh no
drink jam are you serious
maybe dry january really or yeah it just
yeah well can i get some ice cap
thank you actually i want to try can i
try white mike yeah you should try this
japanese whiskey chin
my my whistle i'll do ice water because
my my my own whiskey drops in feb or
february or march thank you
i drink every night dude
but you drink like whiskey pee yes you
don't you get drunk right
i'll little buzzer every now and then
but not every day
all right if you get drunk every day
though i'm not saying drunk but i'll get
a little buzz while i'm watching love
somewhere on the road i've never seen
you like drunk no never drunk
because think i drink you know maybe but
you drink you slow paces
slow pace it oh i'm on stage yeah you
get off stage you're not like
no you're not like that kind of way but
it's good to take a break because
alcohol is poison yeah it's basically
just like my liver
and kidneys working overtime yeah they
can't be good you take liver pills
yeah i take all sorts of [ __ ] yeah yeah
different pills
yeah my girlfriend stuff my girlfriend
keeps trying to get me on these liver
pills
because she says they're really good for
you yeah like so it has a lot of
nutrients i don't know i take a ton of
fish oil
let me know which one oh yeah there's
all sorts of you know i i like that kind
of stuff like uh
i mean the only thing i really take
right now is a vitamin d
that's good that's a covert [ __ ] huh
because it's covered i just like it
i was just kidding but yeah everybody
feels good
i just like the flavor of it
i think i take so many like medicines in
the morning it's crazy i just take
it i'll see you but like you don't
you're not taking like [ __ ] oh let me
wake up and take some dayquil
i'm going to send it to you oh god
did you lose weight cat uh some
you get a cat hang out with stevie
making me eat [ __ ] hard-boiled eggs
all the time oh no
he does not he actually i feel like if i
ate the way he wants me to i would have
gained a lot of weight
i just started yeah he eats really
healthy but he always wants me to feed
myself
i think he's like secretly trying to get
i want you to get thick or something
maybe
i don't know i lost 15 pounds though i
was gonna say good job
yeah i'm like shedding the depression
weight uh depression
yeah i gain a lot of weight when i'm
depressed i gain like 20 pounds really
quick
but uh just started eating healthier
yeah i also found a gym that's open
but the gyms whatever it's made me diet
what you been doing
uh i will cut out because i binge eat a
lot so i'll do like donuts cookies and
stuff i just cut that out yeah i'm in
the middle
oh really oh yeah hey yeah we're getting
there
yes it's a new [ __ ] year
we're starting almost yeah we're
starting to yeah that's how i am i feel
so much better now
[ __ ] without sugar and stuff like
that you want to know something crazy
right now
i've been eating so great yeah right and
then we eat that pizza
i actually don't do you feel weird like
you feel like i don't even feel
disgusted well i don't feel too
disgusted like you know like yeah like
because
all the other food was like like just on
top of it on top of it just
weighed me down but like having the two
slices of that because i've been eating
so good i
don't feel crazy yeah sure you're gonna
die for a week but yeah you kiss my ass
you know man listen i swear you know i
like i said i ain't doing a little talk
about you brenda it's not where you
start it's how you finish you're right
you're right it's not it's not where you
start the starting line it's the finish
happy birthday malek
happy happy birthday
[Laughter]
trying to put the listeners on game it's
very healthy for people oh all the [ __ ]
you take
yeah i don't know i'm saying it help
your legs
what do you mean [ __ ] you take like
supplements or
what's up on this right yeah yes
vitamins and supplements yeah
do you feel better with 15 pounds a lot
for you you're small
yeah i feel a lot better i was just it's
similar with chappelle
i just felt so heavy because i was
eating like [ __ ] i was eating a lot of
carbs a lot of sugar
i have diabetes running in my family so
i really should get that under control
so hard though i feel like the first
five ten pounds is always the hardest
like after i get past like five pounds i
can lose weight pretty easily but the
first five may take me like three months
to get over
yeah and then until you're on strict
diet you get on the scale and you still
haven't lost like man [ __ ] this
yeah see i don't step on the scale i
ain't trying to scales are discouraging
yeah it's super discouraging i can only
imagine for you
they're like brittany you got to get
this weight you got to get that one let
me ask you this when you were
working out and you were training how
often did you look at the scale
rare super rare okay like when you were
fighting yeah
very rare okay well you didn't have to
you have to shed much
nice heavy weight i was heavy and then i
was always i was fighting at
heavyweights so the limit's 265.
i fought between 229 to two i think the
heaviest i was like 42.
okay so they used to have to force me to
eat oh really
always yeah they're like dude get a
pizza you need calories
because i just didn't eat damn why why
were you nervous
i don't know yeah just feel like eating
don't have that problem now
it's weird how the older you get that
the more appetite
what is it i don't know i don't know
what it is you know what i think it is
like i know with me like uh
when i when i was done with cheerleading
yeah and that's when it was like
i don't know i was like oh i can hear
what the [ __ ] i want and i thought i was
just gonna be
that you know be like fine with whatever
the [ __ ] i ate but
yeah that's not how it works yet it's
also like i don't like there's no
there's no sense of urgency like there's
no
i don't have to get in like silly [ __ ]
like if yeah men's fitness called music
hey man you're me on the cover in four
months
then i'd get super strict you'll get to
it but it's just like but if it's just
for you
it's kind of like like i can be like all
right what's tigers whatever we're
celebrating this or yeah it's his
friend's party or my girl
yeah you know she got tamales yesterday
so i'm like what am i what am i dining
for
yeah yeah yeah i'm saying you're a fat
you're the head of the household you're
producing you're the father of that
that get castle yeah i know you are what
you eat
i know so i would like i would like to
be in crazy shape for
for my kiddos though yeah it's dope when
your dad's in shape yeah
my dad was always in shape he was what
do you want would you would you do that
espn cover the nude
oh yeah yeah but don't worry don't stop
it
i want a mouthpiece
we got a organic uh you got your black
seed oil
you got your vitamin 12. you got to get
that you got yours
yeah you guys why don't you just take a
multivitamin yeah it has all this in it
that's all that in no you don't they
don't have comp
they don't have they do if you if you
get that on it total uh
optimization packets would put an immune
supporting
code uh big brown 10 off bro you ever
taking a multivitamin without eating
something fans get that bro bruh how
much does that [ __ ] you
dude i wanna die no you wanna oh my i've
only i've done it twice in my life
doesn't it oh my god but if you take a
photo so you take a multivitamin
i think it just happens to anybody right
you're like you're taking it like
expected
yeah like oh [ __ ] yeah you just you're
just taking a [ __ ] vitamin
but man it makes you feel nauseous why
didn't you make your food
what did you say why you didn't eat
afterwards no it's not eat afterwards
it's like you got to eat
so bad before it yeah you gotta have so
you can't do that on an empty stomach
it's like if you just take it at the top
of your day it bro
it [ __ ] it's the worst thing of all
time the worst [ __ ] thing i want to
hear both of your stories go
no i want to hear both of you you feel
so terrible what were you why did you
take it i was just taking a multi
vitamin why did you take it
uh yeah i you know i always take
multivitamins i took it and
i don't know i didn't think about i just
popped it in and then like 30 minutes
ago i'm like oh my god i feel
terrible you feel terrible you feel it's
the worst feeling it feels like you're
about to puke
yeah it's horrible dude my homie uh he
tried the alpha brain
and i guess there's like a percentage of
people that it makes oh no
he's that percentage oh [ __ ] dude he
[ __ ] him up
[ __ ] him up now i'm scared to try it
no you shouldn't be
i'll give you some no what do you got i
tried it many times
and you're good yeah no problem yeah
what do you think about whiskey chin
not gonna lie not your favorite i'm
gonna be honest i i do think this
jameson bottle for whatever reason
is just smoother so other than this
japanese whiskey so i would say
get another glass and just take a little
sip of it um
but you don't do jameson because white
might was asking he goes he don't drink
jameson i was like i
don't think so not really i've never
seen drinks i don't mind it but it's not
my go-to
let me smell that one
oh we should have chappelle smell this
one too then i know what that smells
like i mean
this particular box where'd you get that
bottle from dude cvs
it's on sale wait what uh it just
happens to you know what what's so
different with that jake no once in a
while you'll get like a bottle that just
tastes a little different
same thing but you know one yeah they're
golden you got lucky yeah
so we got lucky with this one oh yeah
that one smells good yeah this one's
nice
shout out to the florida gators covered
the spread 15 and a half points
shout out to white bike michael turner
game through you
so uh yesterday a truck drove into
zany's
so crazy apparently there was
uh the guy who was driving the truck he
put it in parking and he forgot to put
the um
the emergency brakes on and so when he
got out of the car it started rolling
and he couldn't stop it in time
oh you know what's dope is i talked to
theo and the people at zany's our girl
at zany's the manager there
there they have shows friday really yeah
they're not gonna be out long
awesome yeah that's good apparently
there was no structural damage so
everything's gonna be oh so they can
keep that building mm-hmm
they don't have to clean that up and
cover it up and carry on with the shoes
that's right where the stage is
yeah isn't that the stage right here
yeah the green room is right there
yeah it stays right there green was
right there god damn if it was gonna
happen though that's not a terrible spot
to happen yeah
true didn't have any beams or nothing
but also truck driver what are you doing
it is true dude
shout out to uh big sky they had that
truck he crashed in
as well i don't know so
this was submitted by queen gigi on
twitter dave chabelle
buys a miami-based township and he plans
to turn it into a comedy club miami and
props like
[ __ ] uh
that's that'll be difficult that'd be
dope yeah so this is a fire station dave
chappelle recently
bought it through his the llc that he
owns yeah he's going to convert it into
a comedy club
more comedy clubs the better yeah
miami's popping too for comedy it's
something dope yeah
miami is great for do that have you done
miami improv yes since they've redone it
no i've never i've never in all the land
dude they're always they're always great
same they're the same owners
they're great but as far as like their
their instagram their social media oh
they're on it because they're younger
too the gm's younger
so he just gets it and then i think on
sundays and thursday mornings i don't
know about in covid
but they have like parties there dude
really they have like
in the morning they have like brunch
parties there and they're lit
with hotties
what else you got cat okay
so an la sheriff deputy was actually put
on leave this week because
there was a sound that got picked up by
an open mic
of a woman moaning and they figured that
somebody on the
radio frequency was [ __ ] and they
found
that it was located right next to the
universal backlot where the bates motel
of the tour
of that like uh backlot tour is so
uh yeah they're currently doing an
investigation
but this is the audience wait okay
i'm so confused so hold on let me help
you out he's a cop
and you know how they have their mics
yeah he left his mic on while he was
[ __ ]
while he was on call you know in an open
mic comedy open mic
no no no no like um his little like
walkie-talkie he was so confused
okay i love that song so shout out to
the friends you know he's great
dumbass thank you you're gonna take it
bro i did not i was like open michael oh
my gosh
like i'll have it let me let me hear the
negotiation so it was at the
you said the bates motel thingy right it
was near the basement
so that how funny is that it's actually
on the universal lot by the or
in or by the way it's right here right
by it so that's even
funnier tmz
there's a fellow police officer trying
to say like hey we can hear you
turn it off
you have an open mic
i think the girl said oh my god he
giving it to her
if i was having to be like like uh we
got a suspect here
and she's down she was hit in the
stomach
hey she literally saying [ __ ] the police
what i tried to counter your open mic
and then you just throw it you throw the
show off okay she's
she's living it so he's not just we
don't know yet there's currently an open
investigation but he was placed on
uh leave right away that's tough damn
wait
for him just having sex well
it must happen all the time i had a
buddy buddy in high school his brother
was a cop
and he'd pick up you know he'd arrest
prostitutes and put them in the back
seat
i don't know and be like you know i
won't take you i won't book you if you
suck this dick or let me [ __ ] you so
he was [ __ ] all these like
prostitutes and got fired of course
that's the only way that ends yeah yeah
that's kind of damn
right actually actually if you really
think about it
what all right let's move on what that's
kind of like
you'd be a crooked cop well yeah i mean
all cops are not like like bad but i'm
just saying
him having sex with prostitutes and i
think i am not taking
him to jail
no we have covered now yeah we have
copenhagen never mind
everyone in here has had except for
malik and spell
i i really think i had it that yeah
they've had it
because it was when we were uh in
phoenix june yeah in phoenix
in june yeah and i woke up that sunday
and i had
a headache that i've never [ __ ] had
see that was my thing in my [ __ ]
kobe there was a headache and it was it
wouldn't it wouldn't go away
yeah it doesn't know i took ibuprofen i
was like right here
dude it's like it's weird it's just my
headache mine was over here
yeah and around here and then you all
had got it that
following san antonio doug and san
antonio maybe i believe you have
you might have had him just as wait
malik tested positive for the antibodies
all right
didn't you let me oh that you've had it
before whatever over here
for that so you've had it yeah so you
got to get our jail free card now
well means you can just like lick
people's faces oh okay because they test
me on the xbox and they put it in my
nose and what they say negative
yeah but they're not tests for
antibiotics there so you can only do the
antibodies through blood i feel yeah for
the finger
that's what showtime did but chances are
malek is immune to it for a while
because he's had it yeah yeah yeah
that's why you didn't test positive well
i mean every every time like i've been
exposed to someone and
and taking a test after i always come
back negative you might have had it for
sure
i bet you have it mm-hmm everybody's
gonna have it what else you got
everybody's gonna get it everybody
that's what he says uh this is more
happy stuff
have we heard from our boy vin diesel in
a while i haven't checked this it's
well i follow him i follow him so i
haven't seen anything
pop up that's crazy if you need a
feature oh that's right you do music
so these are happy posts i want to do
this because it's christmas time
all right this is josh brolin he posted
this you know you guys know josh brolin
of course the
great actress i don't know i'm always
like you know i always feel like the
parents
you know do something but anyways let's
just enjoy this
he's thanos from avengers so i can't use
the music but see there's a little
brother
always greets his sister after he comes
out comes back from school oh
amy oh wait hold on hold on play bill
weather
yeah it sucks dude come on oh so every
time he leaves the bus to
that's so cute oh yeah hugs his little
sister bro
she's so excited i could do this with
tiger in boston
every single day tiger does the exact
same thing it's so cute
that is look at that but it's a brother
and sister relationship it's just it's
adorable
fight that's so cute
older sister or younger she younger she
you're younger it's so
cute
so did she used to fight with your older
brother too oh yeah
my sister get down lex is crazy
and yeah this is a scar on the bottom
yeah what else you got
that's so beautiful um another good
story remember chianti johnson
yes bro here at the hospital yeah dude
he made a message
oh let's go all this the florida guy
yeah
who who got like who just dropped out of
nowhere yeah you stopped playing
basketball and you didn't
nope here we go everybody first and
foremost i'd like to thank god
i know y'all haven't sent y'all prayers
out the last few weeks and me and my
parents are very grateful for the
prayers i've been going out to all
daughter and medical staff
at tallahassee memorial and uf chance i
just want to say thank you
for all the support y'all gave me
especially the lady that was in the gym
at florida state
to my gator nation uf athletic family i
just want to thank you for all the
prayers that y'all gave out to me
go gators let's go oh yeah so
thank god yeah did they say what it was
yeah they say what it was i didn't see
anything yeah any updates on exactly
what the condition was
yeah um hopefully you can get back on
the court for sure oh
someone i'm sure we've all saw this tag
right yeah
i haven't seen this all right so no
because you're not social media but they
tagged pretty much all of us on this
it's crazy so it starts off with a guy
who's on this
omegle family
turn it up dog i know
so he says the guy that yeah he got
paired up with says [ __ ] you [ __ ]
because you you like it scans through a
bunch of different people so the first
guy says [ __ ] you [ __ ]
and then he sees this person
do you mind if i play something no all
right
oh we got a love connection to me
[Music]
[Music]
but the loser up top just kept you know
because when he saw him he was like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] he probably has dick in
his hand probably yeah
we remember with cat yeah yeah and then
we saw this biggest yeah
guys wait you you got on this we had
kevin a year ago there were so many
dicks
yeah beforehand
no so it's like a random uh match up
where it's you and then some
stranger you can skip to a new stranger
to talk to if you want to
or you can stay they could step on you
dude's jack
a lot of people just kind of trying to
meet other
people from around the world and a lot
of them happen to be men who are jacking
off so we put chin in front of the
camera
and chin was getting passed up a lot and
so they had we said give us a call
and within like three people big dick
big white dicks jack in it they're
gigantic
i don't think so it was fantastic like i
don't think it's like
can i ask my question how did that come
about but i don't know i've never heard
that
i think it's because you were brian just
found out what chat roulette was oh yeah
were trying to explain to you like why
people use it so you wanted to see for
yourself like are there really people
jacking off and
there was boy them boys are ready to go
nick was already on full salute
full ten hut interesting thing too they
were big dicks it's
i've
[Music]
you may get two guys jacking off at the
same time now how long did you
look check it out and that's why that
troll was like man get the [ __ ] out of
here because he's right trying to jack
it
play the [ __ ] violin or the [ __ ] he
has you know but he had a gamer headset
you know yeah yeah so you can talk while
he's jacking
you know who goes on that amigo a lot
aly mccoskey she's always up on there is
she
she getting a lot of dicks i don't know
probably no no i'm telling you i i don't
know either
but
was this like middle of the day yes this
was like maybe
2 p.m on a wednesday night right now
dude
hold on now they were gigantic i'm not
even joking
they were freaking enormous it was like
it wasn't it was not going to look like
what
what are they if they were that big that
why the [ __ ] they on chat roulette
it's not even like
they have a fetish where they like to
expose themselves what's the
uh term for that like an exhibitionist
or i don't know
like those flashes
2 pm y'all out here guys dude telling me
these boys ready to go
yeah like that cop what else you got jen
all right
where'd i go from here chin were those
dicks big
they were gigantic
big girthy he's all girthy
white ticks man it had to be crazy
though
no they they were so here you know you
guys are a big girthy white dude you
guys give props to tyga
a lot right oh no nothing but i'm saying
it tears looks like thin
and long these guys are just like
gigantic it was a gigantic it was a
shock yeah they're a big white dick yeah
there was a shotgun
big old white dragon
bazookas bazookas yeah veiny bazookas
veiny bazookas what the [ __ ] yeah it was
really fun
i just want to know that conversation
both of y'all was like
yeah let's just throw chin on first
thank god cat didn't sue us
no but yeah chin was all right [ __ ] chin
was on them the guy's like yeah
how's it going guys like you know pretty
good
you know just hanging out check this out
strictly sexual uh not strictly sexual
but a lot of people if you're not
certain people it is very sexual
yeah and like for that guy it was so
valid it was so funny it was funny yeah
yeah we should do it again that's
actually a pretty that's
so funny you know what's crazy about
that there are people who send in their
dick pics to girls only fans and they
pay
them to rate their dicks that's nice
because if
you're gonna wait yeah so make sure
like a girl as it is you might as well
monetize off of it and make
only fans where people will send you
like a tip of five
ten dollars you send them the dick pic
they'll review your dick picture before
you make them [ __ ]
i'll do that right what what what
who said that or reviewing it
no he said he said i'm pretty sure he
said what
we'll be like to cancel you say
[ __ ] i'll do that i'll review like we'll
be the dick staff
oh it's like american idol but for dicks
yeah i'll be the simon calif dick
what would you write it it was dreadful
wait what
switch up the angle lighting what else
you got jen
all right give me one second camera
battery died oh oh
we good now was that a gopro yeah it's
just for the
current events once you when when will
you eat up and run with the new [ __ ]
um i need that lenses first that's what
you're waiting on yeah
switchboard new cameras the switch i
have we need cables we need
the new studio should be imac first we
get january
so once we have all that stuff in i can
start testing it get everything like you
know calculated
dialed in and then it should be dope
that'd be cool we have like we have
badass cameras
that are coming what do we have right
now i can't wait yeah they're sick dude
oh yeah all right i have
one more i actually have two more but i
don't know enough about the story i just
saw it recently
so this is the first one this is a
miracle ohio man travels 20 oh sorry 2
000 miles to save a baby's life
i guess a 64 year old man saw that
someone needed a
liver transplant for this little baby
and it fit
so somehow they got him over yeah yeah
some well so
the kids parents both of them they had
underlying issues so they couldn't give
their own kidneys
and the guy that actually gave it gave
it to this baby he actually
gave a kidney away to someone else
before so he's like a super
awesome dude yeah wow yeah so it saved
this kid's life yeah jesus christ
it's a beautiful story what's w what's
that video right there
it's probably the okay yeah
oh just a healthy baby boy things might
have turned out far differently for the
cooper family had it not been for
the generosity of an organ donor
thousands of miles away
there's so many other people out there
that can do the same thing i did
saving a life and forming a forever bond
so that's that message right like how to
save a life yeah it's a great song
shout out to michael man what else she
got
another another one it's also
emotional hold on more of that kid
singing no
uh so this is from tanks good news i
just saw this
it popped up in my feed it's all good
new stuff right yeah
so yeah this is i'll just play for you
so this is a teacher and you know when
you're a teacher now you can only teach
through zoom because of covid
so these guys all plan something for
them
hold on hold on
i've heard that i've heard that let me
uh refresh this real quick
damn it this new instagram thing with
the
volume sucks dude i've heard that
i've heard that in some classes nobody
turns the camera on including the
instructor
oh my gosh hey here we go
seriously is it my fault that you have
your cameras off
so dr brown we actually kind of wanted
to do
something um with your with your cameras
off
everybody just wanna go ahead
it says thank you guys well you're gonna
make me cry
you ain't the only one dr brown
oh dr brown
doctor yeah that dude over there is
crying as well
you guys how come the one guy the doctor
my one guy didn't do it
again give your sign up homie he was
crying
yeah that's all i got
merry christmas
yeah like i don't even know what to do
he's not even fake tears though everyone
ready for christmas
did you ask santa anything for christmas
uh for me
uh i just want to be able to see my
family again yeah yeah that's it
so you asked for a vaccine um
same same family wanna see your family
yeah
malik um thanks for anything i'm
thankful for everything i have right now
you didn't ask for anything
no it's weird to ask for stuff in it
chappelle how about you
what you think the loser oasis see
always
no i don't ask for anything no i never
do you're comfortable man yeah i'm cool
i'm thankful for y'all
thankful for you thank you yeah all you
guys man
did you ask me anything i mean you give
so much no didn't ask for anything
excited for my kiddos for christmas what
tiger asked for
uh he has some cool stuff coming up that
me my girl fight because
she wants to say santa got it all like
[ __ ] santa you were too hard yeah
so have to give her santa half the gifts
are from me got a half
half an hour so you had to meet santa in
the middle yeah man i'm sick of this
[ __ ]
uh elf on the shelf it's almost done
exhausting yeah exhausting oh you have
to now do you do is for the rest of the
month or do
are you done right after christmas as
soon as christmas it's over because this
morning that [ __ ] is
putting him in you might close it until
next year there you go i thought you're
gonna light them on fire
yeah one more day one more day yeah all
right well next week this cruise in west
palm beach
west palm beach florida the shows are
almost sold out the new year show is
sold out that is west palm beach florida
december 31st that is next thursday
friday
saturday two shows thursday two shows
friday two shows saturday
west palm beach florida uh you will see
us there twerking around in the
lamborghini
and then uh january 29th through the
30th
san marcos texas texas let's ride right
outside austin with
a very special guest at those shows san
marcos texas
uh january 29th through the 30th tickets
at t5k.com
thick boy gear just dropped we got the
thick boy smiley gear going on
uh yeah get it we restocked everything
the thick boy
short sleeve hoodies tie dyes hats uh
fanny packs thick girl
everything's restocked so get it the
gift that keeps on giving
to you thick boy think boy nation out
there go to thickboy.com
uh but west palm beach see you next week
with this crew
k.com we out like sweet
do you think it's the cupcakes in front
of you bernie come on in come on in
this is a prize let me get ready all
right all right
yeah yeah oh there he is
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a basketball baseball thing well
why are you saying it like that why are
you doing it
i'm trying to figure it out i don't know
it's a it's a basketball football thing
that's cool oh that's actually really
dope yeah thank you cool yeah i did a
detroit uh
grand hill yeah
thank you so much
this pizza smells so good yup i got your
cheese slices
oh thank you so much can we dig in
happy birthday how long are we going to
raise
boys
[Music]
okay boys back all right man oh yeah so
this is the
[ __ ] my girl picked out she's gonna have
to be a giant elf a giant [ __ ]
christmas tree
oh damn oh cute
oh you don't wanna dress up for real no
chappelle's gonna dress up
no i'm not let me know i'll put it on
for a second all right well that means
you're dressed
for a second i don't think that's
yourself okay you didn't want to dress
up
you said not do something yeah yeah
whatever you guys want to do
because this is my experience i
i'm thinking next week